welcome everyone
it's more people coming perfect have a
seat
this talk is going to be about what's
new in c-sharp everything that's been
excited about exciting about c-sharp 8 9
10 maybe we'll have some time for 11 and
the next year if I'm invited back to do
this this talk is going to be what used
to be c-sharp and what's now F sharp
because most features in c-sharp
originate from from F sharp
this is funny but true my name is Philip
eckberg it's amazing to be back here
if you have any questions after this
talk feel free to ping me on Twitter
send me an email have a look at my
plural side courses I do quite a bit of
talks on c-sharp and try to stay up to
date with the language
it's definitely my favorite language on
the market and one of the reasons for it
being my favorite language
the favorite language that I've ever
worked with is because it has so many
great language features that let me
express myself in ways that some other
programming languages don't really like
me do
and what's interesting with c-sharp is
that quite a few years ago now they
decided to open source the compilers all
the work of the new language features
everything that's happening in.net and
c-sharp is being worked on in the open
this means that anyone in here could
participate in discussions around
language features that are coming in
newer versions of c-sharp or even F
sharp
or things that are happening with the
runtime
so over the years there's been some
changes to c-sharp as a programming
language that fundamentally change how
we look at architecting our applications
how we look at expressing ourselves
things such as generics is an obvious
one that before generics in c-sharp we
had quite nasty code to achieve the same
things
but now we have a language feature that
allows us to more easily express
ourselves
and another bigger one is async and the
weight so there's a few of these
language features that change how we
construct our applications and write
code to solve our program solve our
problems faster
with less code and hopefully the
compiler lets us write code that is less
error prone and
ultimately makes our applications better
all right so if we're going to
participate in the discussions we can
head over to GitHub and check out some
of the language features that are coming
in c-sharp this here is a snapshot of
features that have already been added to
the language some of them have been
scratched from the language which is
ultimately a good thing because if you
participate in the discussion on GitHub
why wouldn't it also mean that language
features that could potentially make it
into language could also be dropped out
of it
I'm not saying that Microsoft would ever
remove a language feature but if it
hasn't been added yet you might still
have time to give your thoughts on that
feature
give an example of that later on
so before we get into everything that's
new in C sharp eight there's a few
highlights from C sharp seven that kind
of sets the base for what what is now a
really good programming language so in C
sharp seven two seven point three this
was the first version of C sharp that
introduced a point release and I believe
this was kind of a proof of concept that
they could release a minor version of
the programming language without relying
heavily on Visual Studio or relying on a
release of the.net framework or net core
or net or whatever they want to call it
now so
in C sharp seven they introduced this
thing called topples or tuples and
before c sharp seven it was kind of
tedious to have to work with with tuples
this is just a container of of data
container of elements now it's not
obvious what item one two three and four
and five would be in this case here so
instead as many other programming
languages why not introduce this as a
first-class citizen so in c-sharp 7
we have this this language feature which
is called tuples or tuples depending on
how you like to pronounce that
this here constructs a container of or
it uses internally it's a struct that
has some fields on it but it lets you
specify one of these inline types that
you can use as a return type as an input
parameter unless it's past this
container of elements around and you can
even access the fields on that type as
what's their what their names are which
is nice so now we have this first class
first class citizen in the language
allows us to work with a minimal type of
of not an anonymous type but it's a type
built for us using an a generic value
Tuple behind the scenes
so this here alone in C sharp seven
wouldn't make much sense to use it would
let you return multiple return types or
return values but in conjunction with
another language feature called pattern
matching this became quite useful
we'll look at that as well soon
in C sharp 7 they also introduce a
concept of deconstructing an object
if I add this very magic method
signature to my class it allows me to
take an instance of this class and
assign it into local variables
the left hand side look very much like a
tuple but it's not
what happens here is that it takes an
instance of my person and it
deconstructs that into these two local
variables
which I can then access
this again in C sharp 7 wasn't something
that you'd use
at your in your everyday work but
together with pattern matching this
again is a really nice language feature
to get
so even though we didn't have pattern
matching at this point in the language
we could look at different types of
other programming languages that did
pattern matching really well
and we could get that into c-sharp as a
programming language as well
if we look at these two together they
look a little bit similar so here we
have a tuple that's assigned into a a
local
variable called coordinates on the right
hand side there's just two values in a
container of two things assigned into a
variable that has these two fields on it
we could access them as you'd imagine
now where deconstruction comes into play
here and it looks a little bit different
is if I take an instance of a similar
class that has this very magic method on
it I could deconstruct that into two
local variables of X and Y in this case
this is all due to to this interesting
method called here or this adding this
method to the type
so these two features are quite handy
and they set the base for an important
feature an important improvements made
in c-sharp 8 and Beyond
so with C sharp eight the eighth
iteration of the language you would
imagine that C sharp at this point was
done or that you couldn't add more
things but as we see with other
programming languages we do get more and
more language feature that adapt to the
type of applications that we are
building more Mobility means that we
want to make it easier to work with
asynchronous apis file system I O
Network and all of that
pattern matching lets us express
ourselves in different ways that we
might not have been able to do before
so if we keep the topples and
deconstruction and all of that in the
back of our heads and now jump over to
look at c-sharp eight there's quite a
few things happening in this language
version
there are some minor features like
read-only members and another one called
default interface methods or default
interface implementations depending on
when you looked at the GitHub page the
last time
this is also the first language of C
sharp or the first version of C sharp
where it made sense to use pattern
matching while they introduced a variety
of pattern matching in c-sharp 7 and
built the components in the compiler to
make it usable they introduced a
language feature in C sharp 8 called
switch Expressions which we're going to
look at something called using
declarations static local functions
there's quite a few things here another
one that's going to change the way that
we build our software is nullable
reference types completely new way of
looking at reference types in c-sharp
we'll spend some time doing that as well
and we'll look at asynchronous streams
can dispose of things asynchronously
there's ranges and indexes so all of
this here was introduced in a pretty
late version of c-sharp
and when we look at c-sharp 9 10 11 12
it's going to be just as many language
features
which is because many developers come
from other programming languages and we
can take the best part out of that and
make it a part of c-sharp and make it
feel like a c-sharp feature
so if you want to use these then we're
going to experiment with this what do we
do
up until c-sharp 8 the language wasn't
heavily dependent on which framework
version you used but there are some
changes in C sharp a that do require
that you use one specific version of.net
so if you want to use C sharp eight
you'd use dotnet core 3.0 if you want to
use C sharp 9 you use dotnet 5 and so
forth
so this means that if the runtime and
language depend on each other
they could then introduce language
features that would depend on things
added to the runtime which changed the
language a little bit more
one of these features in c-sharp a is
default interface implementations
as a way to add a method body to an
interface which requires the runtime to
understand what a implementation on a
method means
correct so quite a few things to keep in
mind here but this is the supported
structure so it's supported to run C
sharp 10 on.net 6. but I've had a Net
Framework project where I just enable a
newer version of the language and as
long as I don't use any runtime
components the compiler will still
compile code that would have worked with
c-sharp one
it's just all compiler magic unless it
depends on a newer version of the
runtime and if it does the compiler will
tell you
so that being said we can go ahead and
create different projects depending on
which type of runtime we're using since
for example here I have a dotnet
framework project for WPF but I can also
create a WPF application which is now
targeting.net6 that doesn't mean that
it's now cross-platform
everything that's happening in.net and
with framework core the new.net and all
of that it's a totally different topic
on its own
but going forward it's one thing
so I can use the language features of
c-sharp 8 9 10 11 and all of that in in
winforms and WPF it just means that I
have to Port that over to this new
project structure but doesn't mean that
WPF and Wim forms is now cross-platform
there's other projects to allow you to
do that
so if we create a shared library or if
we enable a newer version of the
language in an older project
and the compiler deems that well you're
targeting a runtime where this doesn't
work it will tell you it will tell you
that you're targeting something that's
not allowed
so even though I can use some c-sharp 8
features in.net framework 2.0 for
example it will tell you if you're doing
something you shouldn't
this particular example here is using
something called default interface
methods or implementations
this language feature
depending on who you are either you
really hate this language feature or you
just don't like it
sorry
so this is interesting let's say we have
this interface
we have this I cache here super simple
it exposes a non-generic version of
grabbing something out of a cache let's
say that I want to update this this is a
very popular nuget package someone pulls
this down all the time and uses this and
what happens if I want to add a method
to this that means I'm going to piss
everyone off that uses this interface
because now they have to implement this
that means I can now introduce a method
body on my interfaces so I don't have to
force anyone to implement this
which can be seen as a good thing for
Library developers this is really useful
it means that I can update my libraries
I can update my interfaces which I use
internally myself
but I don't have to force anyone else to
actually implement this themselves
but the problem here is that
the compiler and visual studio won't
tell you that you you have to implement
this yourself
the compilers and and all of that will
will see that there's already an
implementation in the interface so if
you update to the newer version of the
interface there's no warning or anything
like that which would be very handy
so I wouldn't know that I have to do
this so anyone going to use this
one person excellent we'll have a talk
later I want to know why
maybe you're a library developer it's
really good if you're doing libraries
now another feature introducing c-sharp
eight which again is useful this here
you could use this if you want to if
you're a library developer but where C
sharp 8 introduce something that will
change how we look at building software
is is nullable reference types so up
until now everyone that's used c-sharp
notes that a reference type a string a
class an instance of a class it's a
reference it can be set to null
which makes sense
but how about we would like to remove
nulls from the language because nulls is
a a problem
who hasn't gotten a null reference
exception
you're lying I know you're
everyone's going to experience this at
one point or another
so nullability is a problem for quite a
few reasons and how about we tell the
compiler to look at nulls in c-sharp a
little bit differently how about we
indicate that I really don't want to use
nulls anywhere and if I do you're going
to smack me on my fingers and I have to
be explicit about the places where I'd
like to use this
now before we look at how to enable this
the problem with null ability is that it
clutters my code with a lot of null
checks all over the place
and another issue with that is because
there's many different ways to perform
null checks we can use null conditional
operators there's if statements there's
uh argument and all argument null
exception or throw if null there's a lot
of different ways to to throw an
exception or or finals
so that's going to make the code harder
to read but it also it's ambiguous what
does it actually mean to return null out
of a method
let's say that I have a repository to
find a person or find a user if that
returns null does that mean that the
database connection was closed does it
mean that I couldn't find a user
I know that personally I do a Pokemon
try catch all
and I just return all out of all of my
methods and then no one knows what
actually happens
there's better ways to architecture
software so don't don't do that
it also encourages mutability which is a
problem for multi-threaded applications
if we can set things to null that means
that at one point or another we'd like
to change that to an actual value and in
multi-threaded applications that's a
problem because you don't want to be
able to touch objects from different
threads
so how do we solve this
this here is quite ugly and I know
someone here is going to say you can
write this in many different ways sure
enough we could simplify this a bit but
still I'm not particularly fond of
having to add this if this would never
have been an issue
instead of having to perform these null
checks all over the place how about I
tell the compiler to let me know if this
could have been a problem and I can do
that by enabling a feature called
nullable reference types
this is the default in dotnet 6 and
going forward so if you create a new
project this is going to be enabled
you can enable this for a method you can
enable it for one line of code for a
class for a namespace you can enable it
for entire project
I don't believe there's a setting for
entire solution but you'll just enable
it per project
what this here is going to do now it's
going to change how the compiler looks
at these different reference types so in
this case here
we well it's obvious that it's null here
but we get a little bit of squiggly here
telling us that name maybe null
which is really handy
and together with this there's another
thing that we also can do because this
is just a warning the compiler is going
to tell us as well you should probably
attend to this and fix this
how many of you are actually looking at
the warnings initial Studio
I bet you're lying
I'm just kidding so 50 50.
I'm one of those developers that have a
million warnings in my Solutions and I'm
like oh I'll just look at that later a
lot of to-do here I'll fix this tomorrow
and then I never do
so the problem here is that if this is
just a warning 50 of the developers
might not actually fix this and 50 will
so what do we do then we turn on
warnings as errors
which is a great feature we can then say
that whenever there's a potential null
reference exception we're going to have
a compiler error instead
so what I suggest
is that we go into visual studio and we
have a look at how we enable this
I'll go in here and this solution here I
haven't enabled this feature yet but
what this what this is here
just full screen this there's no
warnings there's no errors there's
nothing like that
there's nothing here that looks like
it's potentially a problem
just normal classes and inside my
program here I'm just using these
different things but I know that if I
run this application I'm going to run
into a null reference exception
but I'd like the compiler to tell me
that this could be a problem so I'm
going to go over to either we do this
from the normal project properties we
could do that or we can go into the Cs
proj
and we can indicate here that we want to
enable nullable reference types
there we go
and I'm also going to turn on create
warnings as errors
so I suggest that everyone here
enables enable there we go
I suggest that everyone go ahead and go
back to your work enable nullable
reference types and also treat warnings
as errors and then you're checking the
code and then you go home
let someone else fix the problems
don't do that don't tell anyone I said
that
so now I can click down here and see
that well now I have a few different
problems
now I have four errors that I I should
probably attend to and if I scroll
through the code here
I'll see here that there's a warning
here or an error in this case it's
telling me that this property should be
set to a value it's not initialized
I could fix this there's multiple ways
to do this
I could introduce a Constructor if I
introduce a Constructor the the error
moves from the properties to the
constructors because now
it should be the Constructor that is in
charge of setting these to a proper
value
this means that I should probably take
first
first name and string last name as a
parameter here and I should set these
to their appropriate values
and if I do the warning is now where the
error is now disappearing the problem
here is that I've now changed the
contract of my class everyone that's Now
using this here if you were to do this
at work you would change how everyone
instantiates this class
which is again not really a good thing
but if we remove that again there's
another way that we can approach this
this is not really where the null
reference exception would have occurred
right there's nothing in here that
accesses a property the null reference
exception would have occurred where the
first name and last name is being used
so to figure out where that would be a
problem I could indicate that this is a
nullable string and the this question
marks work with everything you've seen
this with nullable value types before
but now we have a nullable reference
type so I can say here that well now
string can be set to null which is fine
and I'll do the same in my person class
which is using this reference type
so now these are these no longer have
any warnings
all right so then hopefully somewhere
else in the application there's now an
error or
a problem where I would use this and
look at that the compiler now figures
out
that person.details here might not be
set to an instance because I've
indicated to the compiler that this
might be null
this means I'd have to perform a null
check
so if person is an object
we can do this
or it's not null
oh sorry
I'm going to write this as confusing as
possible just to show you how pattern
matching works
so don't do that instead
do person dot details it's not no
and that would also work so the compiler
figures out that I've now performed and
I'll check this is called null State
static analysis
and it is smarter as well because I
could also say if this is null
I'm going to return
or continue to the next one
and it just knows that I've performed
the null check one
uh One Step Above So it tracks that I've
actually checked this right so this is
cool it works very well with pattern
matching it's going to work with normal
it's not or it's not equal to null as
well but it also works with things like
like we all normally use string.s null
or empty
oh sorry
if we do this
it would have worked with that
just trust me
I'll show you
so let's say we access length here on on
that
and we do first name
it would be smart enough to understand
that I performed a null check on that
entire expression as well because it's
null or empty has some magic attributes
set on it so it understands that I've
performed a null check on the variable
that I passed into the method call
so the compiler is doing a lot of really
clever things here to try and track the
null state of our variables this is
super handy
but then again this here doesn't look
very beautiful so I'm not going to do
that
but this here is showing you that we
could
track that this would be a problem but
in this case maybe I don't just want to
perform a null check I can do the null
conditional operator to check that well
maybe we just want to get that value if
it's not null
what I can also do if I remove that
again you'll see that we have a warning
I could also use a null for giving
operator or the damage operator to say
well I've performed a null check the
compiler is just stupid enough to don't
understand what I what I want
this is rarely a good idea
because the compiler is not stupid
I'll show you why so let's say that I
have a person here
person is equal to null
person two is equal to null
it's going to give me a word in here or
an error saying that this is is null but
I can tell the compiler that I'm smarter
than you
and well it's also
just get rid of L1 as well person two
DOT first name
here we go so I could have told the
compiler just complained that I didn't
use the variable
so I could have told the compiler that I
know better than you I know that I've
performed a null check on null and it's
not null
this isn't going to throw any exceptions
it's not going to be a problem during
run time unless you actually try to
access something unless I try to do this
this here would blow up right because
this here is now a null reference
exception
we can obviously see that so we are not
smarter than the compiler the only
reason you'd ever do this is if you are
setting something to a default value
down here at the bottom
for example if I were to do this and I
want to set this to a default value and
I want to promise or just say that I
forgive that this is is set then the
warning goes away again and whenever
someone sets this property to a value it
cannot be null but I'm going to default
it to null if you haven't set it so it's
a little bit confusing but the only
place you'd ever use the null for giving
operator is with the default keyword
just keep that in the back of your head
so again
this here was quite clever and this here
is a really great language feature but
there's one more place where this is is
um it's a problem in this case here I'm
returning a nullable list or I'm saying
that I want to return null where I have
an innumerable I could say that I I
could return a null list or a not a list
of potentially null people as well so
you get the idea you can use the
question marks to indicate to the
compiler that something could be no or
not null
but in this case here I'm going to show
you a little bit of a trick because what
we want to do here is that we want to
yield return
a new person
and we want to set the details to a new
object
with some first name
said to Philip for example
this here is called the target type new
expression I don't have to explicitly
say which type I'm creating and
everything yield return to just build a
list for me so whenever someone's trying
to iterate this it's going to allow me
to do that very nicely
so this here is quite handy and it's a
it's a really nice language feature in
my opinion to be able to find these
potential null reference exceptions
before they occur the whole idea is that
it gives us a little bit of help it's
not going to just magically solve all
your problems
but it is going to let you now find
things that could potentially throw an
exception
all right
so in my opinion
this here is uh is truly a great thing
to enable at least for new projects
so do this only enable tweet warnings as
errors if it's a really completely new
project or you you know that you don't
have any warnings because doing this
enabling this on a large solution
solution can can be
a little bit annoying people we get
pissed off so
with that being said let's talk about
another important language feature that
was introduced in c-sharp it's called
asynchronous streams and this requires
that you understand a little bit of
asynchronous programming so imagine that
we want to fetch some data and we want
to get item by item each item is
retrieved asynchronously so it could be
something that's loaded from disk it
could be a buffer that we're loading
something from but we want to grab the
element process that before we go ahead
and get the next one
to produce one of these streams of data
we introduce the async keyword together
with something called an iasync
enumerable this here indicates what type
of data will be streamed back to whoever
is consuming this this stream of
elements so I could say that this here
is going to produce strings as it goes
on
all right and where the magic happens is
with the yield cure that I just just
showed you so this here will now
indicate to whoever's iterating through
this
um a synchronous list of items that
there's a new element to process each
element is going to be retrieved using
the async no8 keywords
here I'm opening a stream to a file and
disk
and then what I'm doing is that I have
the await keyword here to say that I'm
going to retrieve this asynchronously
while my file system is very fast I'm
going to say that hey I'm doing some
processing using task.delay and then I
can consume this very easily using it
for each Loop
let me go into Visual Studio code and
show you how this works
so we're going to sort of do the same
thing
here I have a method
marked as async using the IAC numerable
this here is going to produce strings
each string is going to be retrieved in
some asynchronous manner
imagine this could have been listening
for items or producing items from a
queue in Azure for example
but here I just have a using declaration
what's interesting here as well is that
this screen will be disposed of when the
stream no longer produces any more items
so after this entire stream has been
processed
could be forever right so this here
could hold on to the file until the
application terminates
and then what I have here is that I have
a while loop to say that I want you to
read the next line of the file as long
as that is an instance of a string it's
using pattern matching to ensure that
it's actually set to a not it's not null
and then I'm going to declare that into
a local variable which I can use inside
my while loop
and then I would test a delay and I
returned this line of text back to
whoever's consuming this
rather simple this here is just
illustrating how we could produce one of
these streams of data
what you most of the time do is you're
the con on the consumer side of things
look at that we have the await keyword
inside in front of a for each Loop
normally
when you use async in a weight you'll
you have something that looks like this
here but what this indicates is that we
are going to get this entire chunk of
data in one go and then we're going to
run through that what this means a
weight for each means that each item is
we're going to go into this this body
one by one as you've retrieved an item
this here is what you would most of the
time use
maybe you don't produce a stream of data
as frequently as you use one another
good example of use case here is that I
could be listening for items on a queue
there's a service bus client for Azure
so you could say that hey I want to
listen for the next item available in a
service queue and and that would use
this stream of data as well or this a
synchronous stream
so now each line will be retrieved
asynchronously so if I run this
let's zoom in here
and do a DOT net run
it's going to read a file and then print
out each line one by one of my favorite
song
hopefully this works
if you don't know the song Welcome to
the internet
all right so this is pretty cool this
could have been then streaming data from
pretty much any place
it's a very nice way of of consuming
data that where you don't have to load
the whole chunk into memory at once but
one by one you're retrieving them right
so it won't call
this line of code here on La until the
for each Loop has processed the previous
element so it calls get next on the
iterator and then it goes ahead and
queries for the next one
pretty simple
but very useful all right
so again we could have used this to to
very easily consume an iasync enumerable
and while many apis haven't adapted this
yet it's going to be be very much
adopted in the next few years
I do believe
just as async and a way to steal
something that a lot of developers
struggle with and haven't really added
to their Solutions all over the place I
do believe this is also going to take
some some time to get traction
so that being said c-sharp 8 introduces
introduces a lot of interesting Concepts
but c-sharp 9 did so too there's a thing
called records which was
they talked about this even way back
with C sharp six and proof of concept A
Thing Called primary Constructors
but that was a long time ago and took a
while to get around building this
feature records is a a shorthand way of
creating a reference type
that gives you value-based equality
and gives you immutability out of the
box
it's coupled with something called an
init only Setter so you get a true
read-only Auto property top level
statements it's what I just used inside
my program.cs it's a completely new way
of producing small applications you can
use it to create apis to do an asp.net
core website with just 10 lines of code
for example
it's a very very very powerful and we're
going to look at all of the pattern
matching enhancements as well both in
c-sharp 8 9 and some of them in 10.
Target type new expression I showed you
that's from C sharp nine and there's a
whole lot of features in C sharp 9 that
was also introduced like it's it's kind
of interesting how you can add so many
features into a ninth iteration of a
language right
some of these are targeting very high
performance applications lower level
programming
but again it's it's interesting to see
that
because of the the open source of the
compilers I believe that it was easier
to add more feature to the language
I'm not saying that every project should
be rebuilt every 20 years even though we
all probably want to this proved that
that was a really good choice
so with that being said we're going to
spend some time talking about the
pattern matching in c-sharp 8 C sharp 9
C sharp 10 and going forward as well
pattern matching is all about being able
to in this case here look at different
traits of an object for example I have a
puzzle piece I have this Ikea poster I
could be looking at colors shapes I
could be asking is this fruit edible
there's many things that we could check
on an instance of an object or what a
thing is I I talk about matching on the
type as well as the attribute of the
object not not in terms of the attribute
you put in in the brackets atop a method
call or a class but in terms of what
color is it edible and those types of
attributes
we've always been able to do this in C
sharp one to C sharp six for example you
would have written some code that looks
like this here if the fruit is of a
particular type
and the color is what we're looking for
imagine if we had to if the color was
actually on the subtype this would have
been much more complex
and we've all written code like this
here it's it's nothing wrong with this
it's just a little bit more more noisy
than it has to be
so that's why in C sharp 7 they
introduce pattern matching which makes
this a whole lot easier
which is a lot more noisier than the
first one
so the reason that we didn't see a lot
of pattern matching in c-sharp 7 is
because it relied on using the switch
we could have used it a little bit with
the with the if statement as well but no
one did at this point
so this is sort of doing the same thing
it's it's grabbing the the instance of
our type it's matching a particular type
and then over here
when we put on the laser pointer here
then over here it's actually capturing
this instance as the correct type so
inside inside this when class here where
I could look at properties with computed
values it would be able to use this as
the concrete type I don't have to do any
casting myself it all just it's done by
the compiler
which you would expect as well
so now in C sharp a they introduced the
switch expression and in C sharp 9 they
added a whole lot of Expressions that we
could use or a whole lot of patterns
that we can use with this here
this looks a little bit different but if
you've ever done kotlin Swift or other
programming languages that have had
pattern matching for a long time you'll
be familiar with this or if you've done
F sharp
so what this is doing here is that
saying I want you to create patterns for
this object
so the based on the input I want to
produce a result on the left hand side
we have what's what's produced out of
this here we can fill this with
expressions
together with patterns so here's a
concrete example of that I can say that
based on a fruit if it's an apple we
return a string this here is the same as
doing an expression body member it
returns that data
this hair is a Discord it means that I
don't care it could be null it could be
any object
as long as as long as they're all
relatable
if this here was an object as in the
type object
you could have matched on pretty much
anything here
so again this is what's returned
out of this this this switch expression
and we're going to spend some time
looking at we've seen the type pattern I
use this in the in the while loop where
I said it has to be a string there's
also a positional pattern which we're
going to look at as well which is used
with this deconstruct method as well as
tuples there's property patterns Tuple
patterns relational patterns you can
append them together with an and or
conjunctive end pattern there's the
disjunctive or pattern parenthesized
pattern negative patterns recursive
patterns it's a whole lot of patterns
right
instead of just talking about them let's
go into visual studio and have a look
and you'll notice that as C sharp is
evolving there's going to be more
patterns added to the language and the
whole reason is that we want to make it
easier
or
the language designers do want to make
it easier for us to express ourselves in
ways that was maybe a little bit more
tedious before so let's say that I have
an instance of I have a type here or
rather it's a record
there's a few things happening in this
class here or this file I have three
record types now these are all reference
types they are generating classes behind
the scenes they give me value-based
equality they give me some deconstruct
methods out of the box and they also
come with something called a primary
Constructor
so here for a failed test it takes the
amount of tests or amount of attempts
the date that I performed my University
test for example or a computer test and
passed these up to a default or the
Constructor of the of the base class
the base class
looks like this
so it has a primary Constructor again
that has these required parameters
when I create a test result I'm required
to pass these parameters
which is quite handy another example of
a record before we look at the pattern
matching
is if I can run this here I've simply
Built This Record of a person has a
first name and last name I'm
instantiating that here the Constructor
requires me to pass these parameters and
after that it's immutable I can't do any
changes to this object at all and this
here on the left hand side I'll zoom out
a little bit just to give you an idea of
all the code that's generated so we have
the backing fields
and then if we scroll down a bit there's
quite a bit of code generated out of
this here it's a class it has a nice two
string method it lets you print this as
a it's a nice representation it
overrides a quality check to give you
value-based equality value-based
equality is where it compares the
properties instead of the instance or
the reference
which is why you cannot use this with
Entity framework because Entity
framework relies on reference based
equality checks
with that being said it also comes with
a deconstruct method down here at the
bottom this will deconstruct it into
whatever you want with the these um with
these properties that you require on the
record so with that being said
I've also added my own so you can have a
record here with a body so I've
introduced a primary Constructor it
generates sort of the same code we just
saw in sharp lab but I've also added my
own deconstruct method so it doesn't
have to give you the same properties
that you have on your type it can be
computed values can do be whatever you
want
so why is this important
now let's create an instance of this
test result
regard to bring in my name space
and I'll say result
or test result rather
is equal to a new failed now this here
requires me to pass the number of
attempts and the daytime offset let's
just say now
perfect looks like a normal normal
instantiation now what I can do here is
that I can I want to get a string
representation of this or it could be
that I want to return a user to a
specific place but depending on what
type of result they got so it doesn't
have to be a string that you return out
of your switch expression but I'm going
to so I'm going to say whatever outcome
rather outcome is equal to based on this
test result
I'll create one of these switch
expressions
this here is now filled with with um
with Expressions now it's going to
complain that I haven't added any yet so
I can start off with um
if I can spell incon
nope
can't Spell inconclusive so let's just
nope here so that's where all other
tests than the ones that I'm looking for
this here is a default pattern or a
Discord so so it grabs everything
I could also say that I want to grab the
result
let's do result here that this will do
the exact same thing so if you use the
Vore pattern which this is called it
would match on nulls so I could use
I could use this over here
it wouldn't be useful if it actually
gives me null but I could access this as
a test result
because it could be any other test
results than the ones that I'm looking
for so let's say that I want to get the
test date here but again this here will
match on anything it could be a null
so I would have to do my null checks
here as well
all right so we have that
now I mentioned the deconstructed quite
a few times and I could use that here as
well so the deconstruct can be used
together with what's known as a
positional pattern
I know that one of these test results it
has
an a deconstruct that gives me three
values the data tests how many days ago
this was and if the test is now archived
for some reason
so I'd like to write a pattern that
looks at what this object can be
deconstructed into
I can say that I don't care about the
first value
and the second one this is why it's hard
because I have to go back and forth
between the code when I write these
tests so let's say it's more more than
10 days ago and I don't care about if
it's archived
how many of you think this makes sense
a couple wow
so when you go come back to this code
tomorrow you'll have no idea what this
actually means right
this here is a relational pattern it's
saying that whatever this object was
deconstructed to the second position of
that deconstruct has to be more than 10.
I have no idea what that was I'll have
to go back again
I could use a name parameter here but
again I'd very much like it official
Studio told me what it deconstructed
into by looking at the the parameters
maybe it's really in a future version
this makes more sense
but I still don't know what it is that I
don't care about so I'd have to add that
here as well
what's interesting here is that this
here will look at all of the different
subclasses as well because this lives on
the base class so as long as any
subclass can be deconstructed into this
this will be a match
but I could also say that I wouldn't be
more specific because since I don't
believe this makes a lot of sense
because you have to go back and forth
and actually own the code and look at it
or inspect the code with something else
or go into the definition
I'd much rather say well if it's failed
and I can capture this inside my switch
here or inside my block here and say
sorry you failed
and I can use this with a string
interpolation if I want to
and I can access this here as you'll see
as the concrete type as well if I could
capture this into this
the right hand side of my expression
here
I could also say that well I want to
only get failed tests
that have a number of attempts more than
two
right so this here starting to make a
little bit more sense
if I were to remove the type here
that would mean any test result so the
Base Class positive and negative but I
can say that it has to be failed and it
has to have a property this here is a
property pattern it's these are the
curly braces
or a cooler bracket so I can say that I
want to look at one of the properties
again using this relational pattern
it has to be more than two and less than
10 for example
so these conjunctive ants to put
different types of requirements together
this here allows me to Now define a
range of allowed values for example
this isn't only useful inside a switch
expression so we could fill this up with
a lot of other ones as well right so
it's passed
I could do that as well so you get the
idea you can use this all of these
different patterns together it doesn't
have to have the same type of patterns
so here's a type pattern
here's a type pattern type pattern with
a property pattern with a conjunctive
end pattern since it's using more than
more than one it's going to be recursive
and then it's using the deconstruct so
you can you can combine these together
to write very hard to understand code
or you use it to write understandable
code
so you can use this with the switch the
switch expression but you can also use
it with a normal if so I could say well
if the test result
is passed and it has a test day or let's
number of tests is probably easier and
we can relate that to let's say more
than 10.
then I could use that inside this here
and if I want to grab this
before I do that what do you think
happens if I negate this entire thing
again it's very confusing right I have
no idea actually without running the
code or running tests for it
be careful when using not not is is
really good for negating an entire
pattern but it's mostly useful with
not no for example where you negate that
it's null
all right let me just go back here
if I want to capture this here inside
this this if statement normally what
you'd have to do is say War passed is
equal to test
is equal to test result as a past test
now we don't have to do this we can take
this variable declaration and put it
over here at the end of the if and we'll
have this inside our if statement
extremely useful
and I don't have to do any casting
myself it's now the concrete type of
what I'm expecting
so pattern matching and the record types
are extremely useful and it's being
continuously worked on by adding more
patterns more ways of looking at
instances properties lists contents and
all of that just to make it easier to uh
to express ourselves
one way to look at this is using for
example an option or a maybe to say that
maybe this returns an object or maybe it
returns a positive result maybe it was
unauthorized maybe it was a successful
attempt and you can use this to
determine where you want a user to be
passed on to for a website example
all right
so we have a few more things that I want
to go through before I'm actually done
so this is all the patterns that we have
in c-sharp so far
which is quite a lot whoops and I'm not
going to suggest that you just know all
of them from the top top of your head
the Tuple pattern looks very similar to
the positional pattern it's just that
instead of us having an object that is
deconstructed it looks at a tuple as an
input
but you can experiment with that on your
own
so C sharp 10 introduces another way of
producing a record
you can use a record struct depending on
where you want that to be located
now I said that record classes are
are mutable record structs or not you
have to append the read-only keyword if
you're doing a record struct
otherwise it won't be read only or
otherwise it won't be immutable
producing improvements they have Global
using directives so we could say that we
have globally introduces something that
we're using in in our entire application
it's a file scope namespace extending
the property patterns that are improving
the Lambda expressions or have done
constant uh in interpolated strings and
there's quite a few things happening in
here let me actually show you that file
scope namespace declaration
I've used it in the example that I had
here but it might have been subtle so at
the top here I have this namespace
declaration this here says that this
entire class now lives inside this
namespace called NDC
it might seem silly why can't we just
have it inside this nested block here
but
you know unnecessary characters passed
into code base or into GitHub is a
little bit unnecessary
all that white space is annoying so we
can just do a semicolon here and it
should just figure that out
and remove it or remove that level of
indentation and the record structs would
look like this so instead of having a
record class the record keyword defaults
to record class but we could do record
struct if wanted read only we'd do read
only
actually read only record struct like
this
might look a little bit confusing but
for those of you that do need value
types this is this is very very handy
all right
so C sharp 10 Again introduces quite a
few things
and one of these is of course
I mentioned this quickly it's a constant
and interpolated strings what this
allows us to do is then use constant
values in interpolated strings which we
couldn't do before
but more useful
um I'd use this but another more useful
feature is inferring the delegate types
of a Lambda
so this here this is C Sharp 9 and this
here requires us to explicitly tell it
which type of Lambda this is or delegate
this is
which seems unnecessary because the
compiler should be able to figure this
out and it can in C sharp 10 we we do
get this out of the box so it tries its
best to figure it out but depending on
the input or what what it has on the
right hand side but it would also be
able to figure out for example if we had
the funk string of int parse we could
remove the string from the from the
anonymous method
makes sense it's it's a handy feature it
tries its best to figure things out for
us
probably one of of my favorite features
is with these top level statements is to
build minimal apis and a minimal API can
look like this here this here Maps the
the path slash ID
to whatever this Anonymous method
returns and now with C sharp 10 we can
have attributes in our lambdas
which again is quite handy
it means that we can produce pretty
powerful minimalistic apis that we can
pass as a part of a larger application
or we can do it as a very much smaller
Standalone application as well
so we all know that minimal apis or
microservices has been a thing for a
very long time but now with this concept
hopefully the micro is actually going to
stay micro and not grow out of
proportion like it normally does in a
microservice
all right so what's next we're about
eight minutes to cover everything else
that's happening in c-sharp for the next
10 years
I'm kidding there's quite a lot
happening to to C sharp
um
the reason I still love C sharp and
still talk about c-sharp is because the
language is evolving and it's evolving
in a way that it feels like every
feature in the language
is still something that could have been
a part of c-sharp from day one it feels
like it belongs in the language and it
makes it easier for anyone that's
starting with c-sharp to understand how
all of the features work
but then again they're going to add more
things and and hopefully all of these
are going to feel like
um they belong in c-sharp as well so
with C sharp 11
was a whole talk yesterday I believe on
on c-sharp 11 and all of its features so
there's quite a lot happening in the
language and it's going to continue that
way as well there's going to be more
patterns a pattern of C sharp is to and
produce more patterns it's going to be a
way for you to look at the contents of a
list for example to match on the content
that you expect to what you get
the name of operator
is you you can be able to say name of
parameter instead of passing the the
type
it's finally going to Cache the
delegates for static method groups which
is a huge performance Improvement
there's this thing called required
properties
so before I had to write some some quite
nasty code to get around the the problem
of I didn't want to introduce a
Constructor when I enable the nullable
reference types but I still want to
require people to set my properties to a
value that's why we could say I require
you to set this property called name
here it shouldn't be null but you're
required to set it and you do that in
the object initializer
and here you see the init only keyword
that makes it immutable or it makes it
you can only set it once
right so after you're required to set it
you cannot change it without getting a
new instance
all right then we have something called
raw string literals
static members and interfaces
I believe I have a slide on that soon
and then utf-8 string literals this is a
really nice language feature it allows
you to say that I have a string and I
want to use that as a span of bytes
working with spans is a whole topic on
its own it's a really interesting type
that lets you work with unmanaged
managed and all types of different
memory memory in in your applications so
here I can say that I have this string
here it's allocated in memory and I'm
going to use this span to say that I can
substring this I can find portions in it
I can slice it off without having to do
any extra allocations
and they've done a lot of work with this
and used it internally in.net and it's
speeding things up quite heavily
an oasp.net uses this a lot and there's
some performance benchmarks on how how
great it is to to do this because you
can pass memory around and you can slice
it off and work with portions without
having to allocate any extra memory at
all
it's like working with pointers in Old C
and C plus plus
super useful but without the problems of
pointer studies
well it's going to get generic
attributes which is a very nice addition
I've been wanting this since probably
the day I started using asp.net being
able to do a generic attribute on a
controller for example super handy
I have no idea why it took 20 years to
build this because it's an amazing well
since C sharp two that is
now
there's another language feature called
perimeter null checking it's a double
bangs so if we were to add double bangs
to a parameter on a method it would
automatically add argument null
exception.throw if null
but it seems like
no one liked that
let's see here so apparently some
auto-generated code is fine but others
isn't so what the feature was was I
believe double Banks like this here and
it would automatically null check this
for you and throw an exception if the
input was null
unfortunately
no one liked it
I did
I liked it but then of course they
remove it from the language
based on community feedback that is
let's go back here so there was a lot of
backlash on that feature so they removed
it out of the language which proves that
doing this open source and getting some
feedback from the community is great
because we can all participate and give
them our opinion
we all love opinions
when working with software
now what's unfortunate with this is that
some teams uh also doing open source uh
in my in Microsoft like the asp.net team
they had already refactored their entire
code base to use this
hmm
I do feel for them like that must have
been quite quite
quite bad anyways here's another one
before we end this there's this thing
called Static abstract members in
interfaces
we work to do this today there wouldn't
be any compiler problems it wouldn't
tell us that I had this static t on my
my
interface I Singleton we all love
Singletons and if you're from java we we
all love this
so but it's not telling me that my
actual person class here should
Implement that
right which is a little bit problematic
so now it's C sharp 11
this here's a preview feature but if we
do static abstract it would then
indicate that the person class actually
has to implement the interface
which I would have thought it would do
without that abstract keyword but this
is a preview feature and hopefully it's
uh it's going to make it into the
language not all of us does uh does I
Singletons or single tones but this here
does going to tell us that this doesn't
Implement that
so with that being said there's quite a
lot happening with c-sharp as a
programming language and going forward I
do believe that there's going to be much
more features added to the language
which has developers that have been
working with c-sharp for a long time can
be a little bit confusing and can be
hard to keep up with all of the language
features that are added
but tools like resharper and tools like
Rider and tools like everything else
that comes to visual studio in terms of
refactoring is going to try and help us
to write our code more effectively and
efficiently to make it also more
readable like we want the compiler to
help us write better code not just write
code that's faster like we saw with
pattern matching we can write code
that's really hard to understand and
read but ultimately we want to write
code that's easier to maybe show someone
in the business because we all want
opinions on our code from the business
side of things
but if we can show them that hey I
translated this criteria into a pattern
it makes it easier to talk the same
language and I think that's important
so with that being said I have a lot of
things on plural side I have a lot of
courses on c-sharp and
Python and all all kinds of things check
that out if you like my stuff and it's
been a pleasure being back I hope to see
you again next year so thank you so much
for for coming along
[Applause]